Okay so we've talked about onechart
businesses before and this is the idea
that you could be the midwit in the
midwit meme where you got to explain and
analyze and give you 10 reasons why this
might be a good idea the pros and the
cons and you're overanalyzing it or you
could just be the badass and the badass
the Jedi it just puts the one chart up
and says this is why I'm doing what I'm
[Music]
doing
all right we're back just Sam and Sean
back uh the band's back together for the
first time in a long time um you have a
bunch of topics but I want to kick us
off can I kick us off okay go have you
ever read the book 48 Laws of Power I've
never actually read it but I've read
some of the laws It's a Wonderful book
it's cool and there's one law where it's
law number 25 and it says you know
something like be able to reinvent
yourself and the author says create
yourself with a powerful new image that
stands out and draws attention rather
than letting others Define you then
change your appearance and emotions to
suit the occasion or stage riveting
dramas as backdrops for your
actions and I love this book and that's
that's that's law number 25 where he
talks about changing your image there's
a person who I've recently discovered
that has done this excellently and I
think that you and I can learn a lot
about him and so there's a rumor about
this guy they say that if you arrange
seats like a boardroom he magically
appears
so this guy listen to his uh listen to
his background so he graduated from
Stanford then he went on to join Google
at the age of 22 where he was the lead
product manager and he helped create
Google Maps after that he started this
social networking site called friendfeed
which he sold to Facebook and Facebook
Incorporated it and one of the big
things that Facebook took from it was
they actually created the like button
because of it he sold that for about $50
million few years later he becomes the
CTO of Facebook after after that he
founds a company that I can best
describe as a note taking company but
for Enterprises he sells that to
Salesforce for $ 750 million after a
couple years he becomes co-ceo of
Salesforce which I think what do they
worth hundred billion dollars more I I
don't even know hundreds of you know one
of the biggest companies in the world
then he becomes chairman of the board at
Twitter he's chairman of another really
large publicly traded company that many
people haven't heard of they make
security cameras he's also on the board
at Shopify and last night he was named
chairman of the board of open AI this
guy is amazing he's only 43 years old
you know who I'm talking about one and
only Brett Taylor that's right do have
you ever like spoke or hung out with
this guy I had a dinner once uh he was
there and uh but we were on opposite
ends of the table so he was at the far
end on on the head of the table that way
I was at the far end of the head of the
table the other way um it was like a
slope of like success like most
successful person on that side of the
table and least successful person over
here I was like the bottom of the puddle
at the bottom of the slide there so it
was uh he's a good dude though he good
energy good jokes um yeah he seemed like
a good good time but he also seemed like
the guy that could flip a switch would
be incredibly serious if you wanted to
so the this guy is so fascinating and
I'll explain why but that's funny that
you're at a dinner with him because he
credits that as being one of his reasons
why he is where he is and so starting at
Stanford and then at Facebook he started
attending these dinners and he said that
like Marissa Mayer when she was early in
her career would go to these dinners he
said that uh Cheryl Samberg was there he
he like Mark Benny off or not Mark benof
the guy started Zinga uh was there he
said that like all these amazing people
would go there and that's actually how
he got to know Mark Benny off from
Salesforce was at these dinners and I
was doing research on this guy and
there's very on Bret and there's very
little stuff about him there's not too
much stuff about him for given how
impactful he is and I found this old
video about 15 or 10 years ago with him
and Mark Zuckerberg they're sitting at a
table and they're it's almost like the
like a post UFC fight press conference
where they're just like sitting there
and there's like reporters it's like
really a press conference announcing the
acquisition of Facebook or a friend feed
to Facebook and he's wearing like a
scruffy t-shirt like he doesn't look
good his hair is messy whatever he looks
exactly like you would think an early
Facebook engineer looks and so I watch
this video and then I see another video
on YouTube where it's with him and the
figma founder at a conference and he's
wearing something like what what I'm
wearing which is like he looks like a
corporate guy but he's still got
Charisma and uh the founder of uh figma
Dylan he asks him like what's been your
biggest learning of your career and
Brett goes well you know I remember
being at Facebook and I was like it just
wasn't working out for some reason and
Cheryl samber said something to me that
like changed my perspective and the next
day I said to myself instead of getting
the company to change to me I'm going to
change to do whatever the company or job
that I'm at needs to have whether that
means how I dress how I act and what you
what you notice is a shift in his
demeanor all the way from how he dresses
so he starts wearing different clothing
sometimes when he's supposed to be this
like tech nerd and someone wants to come
up to him with engineering advice you
see him dress like an engineer then he
becomes Salesforce CEO you see him start
dressing different he's wearing the
classic plaid shirt suit with brown
shoes the classic look and it's really
fascinating to see this guy's demeanor
change and later on in some of these
videos with him these interviews the guy
just like screams Poise you know like
when you think of the Salesforce CEO you
think of like one of these guys could be
chair of a of a important board like
Twitter he just like scream like he's
definitely has Charisma he's got Poise
he's not vulgar at all he's he he
doesn't seem crazy emotional but he
smiles at the right times and he dresses
like the part and I thought it's really
fascinating to see this guy's Evolution
and for him to say that at a conference
and I thought it was exactly what Robert
Green talked about where he talks about
Reinventing yourself and a lot of times
guys like you and me or people listening
they think clothes don't matter they
think you know I'm just going to curse
and people are going to think that I'm
real and all this
stuff I've grown to think that's
complete nonsense that like you know we
act like we shouldn't play this
bureaucratic political game but I think
the more we deny it the the more we
actually need to embrace that and Brett
Taylor is a really fascinating person uh
because that's one of the examples that
I've noticed you're take away from this
whole thing you tell this beautiful
story you have these amazing points but
the big one that stood out to you was
you got to dress better that was the
whole thing no my point is is that
appearance and demeanors matter and
dress is one attribute of that my point
is is that when I look at him like I
first of all the guy's a genius so when
there's these stories about him when he
launched Google m Maps there like the
code sucked and over the weekend he
rewrote it and it was awesome and by the
way the guy who tells that story is Paul
buite the guy who created Gmail built
Gmail inside of Google and was one of
the co-founders of YC combinator and so
for Paul buite to go and say he said in
that thing he goes Brett Taylor's not
just a a great engineer he's not a 10x
engineer he might be a hundred or THX
engineer he's that good to get a
compliment like that I mean it's like
Picasso saying you know this guy's handy
with the brush right it's like okay that
means something depending on who it
comes from somebody who actually worked
side by side with him I think they
co-founded friend feet together
also our software is the worst have you
heard of HubSpot see most crms are a
cobble together mess but HubSpot is easy
to adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better yeah so
he's a genius so like he has like that
part so there's no doubt about that he's
got that's 90% of this or 80% of this I
mean he's brilliant but um and he and he
does a really good job of making big
shots like him and so there's like an
example where Mark benof was like yeah I
used to attend these dinners with him
and he did a great job of asking good
questions those dinners are hosted by
Michael Burch so Michael Burch is uh
hosts this like CEO dinner Benny off's
in it Brett Taylor's in it that's how I
got to go to it um I think we did an
episode on this a long time ago like
called I went to a Billionaire's dinner
or something like that and it was I got
to go as a guest like each time they
host there's like the Main Stays which
is like Reed Hoffman and whoever and
then there's um mer Myers in there and
then it's the the host can invite two or
three guests like new new people fresh
blood into the into the mix and so I was
a one of the fresh Bloods I guess that
time was it awesome uh yeah it was
awesome I mean it was it was amazing uh
you know this just it's amazing to be at
that table I guess um the interesting
thing was like I think I've said this
before which is um if you want to stop
making money the priority hang out with
people with a lot of money because the
conversation was not about business and
money making and you know the markets or
investing or hot deals because these
guys are like post economic they're past
that so it's not that they don't do
those things it's that that's like it's
like if somebody brought their to-do
list to dinner it's like oh come on man
like we're we're here to have a good
time what are you doing here and so all
the conversation at dinner was about
things that were you know nonfinancial
it's like you got your status by having
non-financially related things to say
that makes sense yeah yeah yeah money
was lower low on their hierarchy of
needs you were low on you were only
addressing like the low thing that's
super Satisfied by them but if you had a
really unique experience or you're like
oh dude I take this drug it's this I you
know you lick the back of a horn toad
and you trip out for four hours
everyone's like tell me more and it's
like wow you guys really want to talk
about triping ball it's like yeah that's
what they want to talk about or it'll be
there was a neuroscientist there who was
talking about you know all of his his
lab or he studies the brain and the
effects of both these drugs but also
like a whole bunch of other interesting
like psych studies essentially and
everybody was fascinated by the brain
dock it's like you know if hubbin was at
the dinner it's like everybody wanted to
hear huin um not they didn't want to
hear about you know this great private
Equity deal that you did you know and
how you're getting you know you 45% cash
on cash return that just doesn't matter
at that table and so it was I to me
actually that was the biggest takeaway
was like at these things like you know
humor matters stories matter different
things matter but like it's pretty
interesting to hang out with people who
have achieved all the things you want
because they no longer care about all
these things and uh it's a good reminder
that uh you know don't get to totally
wrapped up in just the the kind of the
business only like I am a business nerd
I do like that stuff but you know the
people who have sort of the high have
played this game at the highest level
they uh you know their their game is now
about this variety of experiences and
and totally un unfinancial
non-financially related things that they
talk about yeah by the way sorry one
last point on that if you if we hang out
in a group of like our peers how many
times is the conversation about who
knows like uh you know content and
followers or investment or deals that
they're doing or like new businesses
that they're bootstrapping or creating
and it's like it's like the contrast
between you know our group is kind of
like early 30s uh age um and then these
guys were all probably like you know
closer to 50 um and so you know that in
that 20 years I think you know what
changes is uh if you're talking about
like you know how this piece of content
went viral and popped off and you got
all these followers like you're
literally a loser if you're talking
about that at that table and so it's
like at each table what's the discussion
like and uh well in the minimum net
worth at that table was probably $500
million well I was there so no the
minimum was lower than that but the uh
median was probably that
yes well I when you were there so here
here's one of the reasons why I'm
fascinated with this person is because
with Brett is because smart people
referred to him and when I think that
when I when I think of I'm I'm not in
the league where I even totally
understand chairman of the board and how
it interacts with the CEO of a large
company but I imagine that it's like
part therapist where you don't really
need the answer but you're good at
asking the right questions and in order
to be a good therapist you have to have
this image well in a reputation uh and
track record of like this guy somehow
gets to the helps me get to the right
answer or somehow like he's got that
Sensei Vibe and I don't know if he's
particularly smarter than anyone else at
that table I imagine they're all just
the best of the best was there something
about his energy that stood out or were
they was everyone quite good at that he
was very poised he had a booming laugh
and and at about two hours into the
dinner he was like that's all for me
boys jacket on left and like and the
dinner like dragged on for like you know
another hour and people trickled out
from there but he was sort of like um
I've had a great dinner I also have
things to do and um I own my time and my
schedule I'm out of here and I thought
that was like a very obvious like it
like a very obvious moment where he was
like cool I you know 80% of the meat is
off the bat now fantastic um you know I
got kids I got I got a board to go go be
on or whatever and he bounced uh it was
just kind that part was kind of funny
but again I was on the other side of the
table I didn't talk to him directly too
much uh I will say a couple things so I
think you're uh reinvent yourself is
actually the right takeaway I think this
guy's had a prolific career as a PM at
Google then a startup founder then CTO
of Facebook then started found her again
but now BWB Enterprise and then sold
that to to Salesforce and you know they
they kind of Mark benof was basically
grooming him to like you know take it
over even the Twitter thing he's not
just a board member like he was the
board member that basically forced Elon
to stick to his offer he stood up to
Elon and and basically forced Elon to
buy and got an amazing deal for the
Twitter show holders whereas you know
Elon was applying a lot of pressure at
that time to tr and and Brett stood up
to him in a way um and he's just a
trusted neutral Third Party U like in
crypto this happened where there was
this one guy who was this like meme
poster but the whole Community just
trusted this guy cuz he had been in it
for a long time he had because he had
been in it for a long time he had
already gotten rich in crypto so it
didn't seem like he was trying to get
rich off anybody or make a buck off
anybody uh he had a podcast so people
heard him talk is this guy Kobe and uh
he had a podcast so people heard him
talk all the time and so whenever
somebody needed to make a deal in crypto
as like a bet like A10 million bet they
would just wire the $10 million to Kobe
as a trusted neutral third party and I
just thought that was kind of amazing
like this guy there's no contract
there's no nothing it's just a social
social reputation and I think that's the
Brett Taylor thing like they brought him
into this open AI thing because he has a
social
reputation people find him when they
need somebody who's going to be a um you
know a voice of reason a stable third
party a trusted neutral voice and um
that's that's just an interesting job to
be done so so yeah I think this guy's
very fascinating my point is is to do
the right thing is actually not terribly
challenging like to be this Kobe Guy
where you're trusted he like well you
just got to follow through no matter
what to carefully craft after reputation
I think takes a lot of discipline and I
find that to be challenging and I'm
really fascinated by these guys who are
able to do that you have to have a lot
of discipline you can't like everything
matters whether it's your dress your
website all you just are into dressing
well right now and you're looking for
examples you're like see that justifies
my enthusiasm around this right now let
me give you another example so Josh
Kushner wait wait hold on hold on True
or False you decided you wanted to level
up your style before you had this epy
about Brett Taylor correct like recently
the last few months somewhat I want to
figure out how to become more I want to
level up my life and dress is one ways
one way to do that what did Deion
Sanders say he said uh dress good look
good feel good play good that type of VI
yeah okay fair enough fair enough
another example is Josh Kushner so a lot
of people know that Kushner because
Jared Kushner was I don't even know what
his role was on the Trump Administration
but Josh Kushner is another guy who's
really fascinating he does a he has a
similar Vibe where he was 24 or 25 he
started uh Thrive Capital he ra I mean
he came from wealth so it's not like
coming from nothing but he raised money
from I think Benchmark or general
General Catalyst I think in order to
create this Venture fund invested in
Instagram a few years later he starts
Oscar which went on to become a
multi-billion dollar Health Tech I think
health insurance business he started um
what was the other one it's not Compass
it's another it's a real estate
investment platform that is uh a fairly
large company and then throughout this
open AI drama as well as other stuff
he's been in the mix and he's done a
really good job of building up this
reputation if you go to thrive I think
it's Thrive capital.com their website it
says nothing it literally just says
Thrive Capital like you can't like he
the guy like but here's the thing is he
does zero flexing which in itself is the
flex and in itself is like the
reputation building you know what I mean
and I and and I find it fascinating to
figure out how are people shaping their
image and are they being how deliberate
are they being both of these guys
examples I think they're very deliberate
even if they even if they try to give
the image of they're not trying that in
itself is trying you know what I mean
let me give you a different example so a
different guy very successful who has
reinvented himself and in my opinion
this is like doing money the right way
this is like what I want all my rich
people to go do not all if you're if
you're just wired like a psychopath you
got to go creep keep Crea you're El mus
you got to go keep creating the next big
thing all right fair enough but here's
here's something I do like so
traditional money path is in our world
you start a company you grind it out for
seven eight years 10 years you sell it
you're rich you uh take a year off you
travel you uh get interested in health
you go on a health kick for a little bit
you um you spend time with your kids and
then you're just like okay this is cool
but I kind of like this in small doses
all right uh I guess I'll now start
investing I'm a VC I think I start the
the vest appear materializes on top of
your chest magically and uh you're
you're like should I be on the board of
this company am I Brett Taylor you uh
you're on boards you're you're writing
important checks into important
groundbreaking companies and that's your
life and then you just do that life for
a while and then you you say things like
my Founders or one of our Founders is
doing this yeah you start using the
Royal Wii as if you're involved those
companies you know you're uh you're
5-year-old you're paying $882,000 a year
to send her to kindergarten in uh San
Francisco and you you made a donation
and they there's a bench in the library
with your name on it although they kind
of promised that the whole Library would
be named after you but it's just a bench
and you're a little bit pissed off about
that but you don't want to say anything
let's not cause a scene um and so you
you know this is your life and here's an
alternative okay you are TJ Parker you
know who TJ Parker
is no who's this TJ Parker was the
founder of pillpack and TJ Parker looked
like he might be going down this path he
he starts pill pack you know going to
democratize them pills or
something I don't know what the tagline
was but he starts pill pack and it's
some sort of like you know I don't know
pharmaceutical far online pharmacy type
thing sells it to Amazon for a billion
dollars okay stage one complete becomes
a VC immediately stage two complete but
then starts doing dope so if you go
to TJ Parker's website you can see some
of the dope he's doing is he looks
and he looks cool looks cool first of
all looks more like whm Hoff than he
does Jamie Diamond so you already know
this guy's going into the health kick
you know the right direction he's out in
nature he's Barefoot sometimes like he's
doing that kind of thing so check out
this thing called the warehouse if
you're one of these people who's into
dope cars which I'm not but but uh you
know you you kind of are you're into
these like cool you know oldfashioned
cars and stuff like that you you need a
place to store it and a lot of people do
the J Leno thing and they get like an
elevator in their garage and they try to
stack four cars in their garage eight
cars in their garage just this gets
tough so instead they built a beautiful
Warehouse to park and store your
beautiful cars and you could share it
with other people but they're like cool
guess what you guys will all probably
get along too this is not just storage
so first they were like we're not just
going to store cars you might have some
wine guess what 2500 wine seller
temperature controlled humidity
controlled beautiful wine seller here
too so store your wine store your cars
and come hang out come hang out we got a
gigar bar we got art displays we'll
watch the games together and it's a car
Social Club so it's basically Soho House
for dudes with a little grease on their
hands and I love this idea this is a
brilliant idea and the photos make it
look so badass I don't even like cars
and I saw these pictures and I was just
like I guess like hey uh D clear my
calendar I got to go learn how an axle
works like I I want to be a part of this
just on seeing the photos and so I think
this is a brilliant idea I think this
could franchise and be across the
country I think you could have you know
locations all all across the country for
this I think guys need Community
friendships mail bonding and but they
don't want to you know it's like guys
will start a podcast podcast instead of
do therapy guys will join a get a car
Hobby and drop you know $300,000 on cars
and join a car club rather than you know
go to go to men go to a men's group and
it will function as such and so I think
this is a brilliant idea
that has national no wait International
consequences if they want to roll it out
where is this it looks like so they
don't say the location exactly it's in
Utah because that's where this guy is
also classic move picking Utah then
here's some of the other projects that
are he's working on if you go to Just
teacher parker.com backc Curren hyphen
projects all right so here's what he's
got going he's producing a documentary
dope love that on cars yeah he's got a
company that just makes really dope
quality bags and gear for people who are
like going to the outdoors and he's like
look this we're going to hold the
quality bar so he's got this company
called lazy Sun he's got a 12 Acre Farm
that he owns he's like yeah farming I do
that too I'm a gentleman farmer and
then I mean this guy's doing even better
he does this he has a business like goes
to Children's Hospitals and transforms
them into like dope art galleries for
the day so that the kids have something
awesome to to see and he's like you know
we we can you can heal kids through
through ART you know like capture their
imagination distract them from you know
the the sort of the mundane like if you
ever been in a hospital environment it's
like one of the worst environments like
yeah does not pass the vibe check and
the fact that he's like oh yeah we're
gonna do these popup art exhibits inside
Children's Museums to shift the vibe I
with that and so um these are this
is a guy who is successful but then use
the money and the time to craft a dope
life around the hobbies that he loves he
went The Joe Rogan path versus the Elon
Musk I need to work 95 hours a week at
just bigger better More Money More Fame
more power more Prestige more everything
um more more suffering and I just
with the TJ Parker path more well by the
way I'm not saying necessarily that I
think the the Brett Taylor path is p i I
just I I guess what I'm saying is I
appreciate paths I appreciate people who
are who who do the damn thing you know
like I can get as much inspiration from
an artist as I can a billionaire you
know just people who just put their
stake in the ground and say this is what
I am and I'm doing it uh yeah how much
do you think this guy so they raised
$100 million they sold for a billion was
he the only founder I think there was
two guys um wow okay sick guy right this
is amazing by the way one one of the
things that both of us really like to do
that I don't think we really put a name
on it which is I am fascinated by and if
I could say what is the number one thing
I am looking for in life it's like what
are you looking for you looking for a
partner or a project or a a to make a
book or way to get famous no no no I am
searching long and hard for people who I
think are playing the right game the
right way so I'm interested in different
blueprints of like what are people doing
with their time and their talent oh
Brian Johnson said I'm gonna
donate my body to science while I'm
alive and he's try to reverse age which
is like just a badass science experiment
mixed with a badass like Health kick and
investment in himself mixed with just
like you know picking a project that was
uh not another business and I think
that's cool but it's not for me and I
think what you described you know the
Brett Taylor where you you start
multiple companies then you become a
board member and you become this
respected luminary of Silicon Valley and
you're the CEO of a publicly traded
company cool game definitely not for me
and uh you know you see some guys who
are like I'm gonna um tweet every day
and I'm going to be super consistent and
I'm gonna do this not for me but and I
just look around and I see I'm looking
for people who are playing a beautiful
game and the sad thing is it's VE for me
it's very hard to point to somebody and
like I can't give you a I'm looking hard
for this and I can't name more than like
two or three people whose game I really
respect I think oh they're they're doing
they have a great blueprint for what
they're doing in life and um I think
that's the most important thing because
once you have that blue BL blueprint for
you for you for myself yeah like I you
know oh I really like how this person
has architected their life I like what
they're working on they seem to be
really happy they have a great mix of
kind of like family and fun and
Challenge and whatever else um and
they're you know doing good in the world
in their own way and you know like I
like I want to see examples of people
doing that really well so I think when
you bring up Brett Taylor we bring up TJ
Parker these are part of that that
search that I have that Quest that I
have the thing I am most interested in
right now and I think that anybody once
you once you get past the kind of like
your needs are fulfilled stage um like
you know instead of striving for
you money you should strive for like
what is the right game to be playing uh
what is a great way to use this you know
this thing called life and uh and get
inspiration from a bunch of people then
sort of craft your own version of that
that's what I'm trying to do at least no
and that's that's exactly the point I
was trying to make which is whoever we
talk about I don't I don't necessarily
want to emulate that but I emulate the
people who are making the life that they
that they've chosen to make and I
consider that to be success one thing
that I've learned from hanging out with
some of these people I
admire is even though it looks amazing
on the outside everyone still has
similar issues whether it's family
issues or pressure on this or that um
and so I always like getting to know
these people like Rob Dear Dick I I've
I've loved having him and on and I've
been able to talk to him once or twice
afterwards it's like everyone's
still stinks once in a while though and
that always has given me a ton of
confidence and actually made me happier
you know what I'm saying right right
right what do you want to do all right
I'm gonna do a quick one so this is
called the Dr Dre question and this is a
question that is useful when you are
hiring so uh I was watching this old ass
Tim Ferris episode where he interviewed
this guy that I never even heard of Cal
fussman you know this
guy uh is he a journalist uh he was kind
of like a journalist or he's like a
writer uh but basically he's like a man
who very interesting life like he boxed
Julio Chavez and like he did like a
bunch of interesting things during his
life and so anyways old episode Tim
Ferris actually it's a very good episode
and one of the things he talks about is
um so his his things like you know the
art of asking questions and uh you know
one thing I like to do is study people's
lives another thing is I like to I'm a
collector of questions um a great
question is like very valuable to me so
I was interested in this episode and
during it they say uh there's a part
where you go okay you know you've talked
to us about asking questions um uh
what's you know who who have you helped
you know who's come to you for help with
asking questions he describes a a a set
of Founders and they said um they said
you know we have this problem with our
company we are super passionate about
our business but when we're hiring we
don't know what to add we're like kind
of hiring the wrong people because we
just can't seem to find people that are
as passionate about our business as we
are and like on one hand we could say
maybe just nobody's going to be as
passionate about our own business as we
are but we just want people at least
close to it right like people just have
a lot of passion we don't know how to
filter for that because if you ask
somebody your passion they say yes so
what do we do and he goes uh he goes oh
that's easy just ask them the Dr Drake
question and he goes he goes here's the
story he goes I was interviewing Dr Dre
um when he was like a journalist and
he's like I said to him what's hey Dre
um doc what's the longest that you've
gone what's the longest that you've gone
on on a project without sleeping and he
goes oh man when I'm really into
something I care about I'm in the zone I
don't even think about sleep I forget to
sleep I'll just keep going until it's
until I you know pass it could be 20 72
hours and he goes um so I thought I took
that idea 72 hours he goes just ask that
ask a person this what's the longest
you've ever gone on a project you were
passionate about without sleep and their
answer will tell you a lot either
they'll struggle to even come up with a
number because they don't they've
actually had an obsession a project
they're so passionate about that they
kind of became a degenerate they let
other parts of their life go like
sleeping and eating and talking to
people and answering the phone and they
just got completely lost in it um either
they'll that will be unfamiliar to them
or it'll be familiar to them and you'll
be able to tell that right away so
that's a fork on the road and he goes um
and it'll tell you a lot about the
person if they say you know what I get
eight hours of sleep every night because
that's I function best when I'm like
that and I'm fully charged and you'll
know okay uh you might not be the right
person for this you might be right you
that's what I want my CFO but it might
not be who I want as my you know head of
product right-hand man during you know
while we're figuring out this Pro from
scratch and so uh the Dr Dre question I
thought is a wonderful little thing I'm
stealing a question I've collected in
terms of being able to find the people
that have that same streak of obsession
and degeneracy that is like if you have
that it's a very high likelihood that we
can work together or we get along what's
your answer what's your answer 48 hours
would be would be mine I've never done
72 not even close but 48 hours for sure
multiple times and the funny thing is
it's on really stupid stuff like uh I
basically did that with that all-in
video the other day um like I was up all
night basically editing it and then I
because I was like I just want to ship
this I want to finish this and I also
don't want to work on this for more than
like I gave myself a day to do this so
I'm just gonna work non-stop for 24
hours on this and I was like that day I
was a bad dad I was a bad husband I was
bad at Fitness I was bad at sleep I was
bad at eating but I was amazing
at that video and like that's happened
to me many times in my life happened
when I was like when we were doing our
first startup I remember many times me
and my buddy Trevor we would stay up and
Trevor would keep going Trevor's answer
would be more like 72 hours but like we
would stay up we'd be like we would see
a cool commercial and be like can we
recreate that it's like I don't know I
know download Adobe let's find a cracked
version of Adobe on Napster and like you
know download this and then we'd be
like okay Adobe fireworks is a way that
you can animate something and we would
sit there and try to learn it watching
tutorials and we would just try to get
better at it and then like I would pass
out and go to sleep on after the
storytelling part was done and Trevor
would stay up and he would learn like he
taught himself Photoshop and after
effects and all these things but he
didn't teach himself in years he taught
himself on like four projects that were
just like these like 72-hour binges and
then he just knew how to do those tools
after that and like now his whole career
is like that but at the time it was
unnecessary at the time we weren't
getting paid for it at the time the
things we made weren't even that good
they were still like you you know kind
of janky but it doesn't matter is 72
hours three nights is that three nights
I think you I would count 72 hours as
you you basically uh you wake up you
work you skip that first night of sleep
you work through the next day you
basically skip the next night or you get
a couple hours the next night and you
wake up and and you finish the next day
that's insane I mean I've I've done uh
overnight stuff a bunch of times all
nighter right yeah an all nighter and
then all day day that next day but like
usually it's like i' I've been at the
office and I'll sleep on the couch in
the office for like from like 4: to 8:
or something like that so it's really
hard to go it's hard to do overnight and
then keep going the next day that's
that's challenging maybe it'll be like
three hours I've done overnight stuff a
bunch of time but it's hard to go more
than that let's say you had like a New
Year's Eve party and it was going to get
a little crazy and you have this friend
and you're like okay I hope this is not
too crazy for my friend and if you just
asked him the version of the Dr D
question is it's like uh hey have you uh
have you ever blacked out when you drink
and if they're like no or one time it's
like you should probably hang back from
this party but if they're like oh like
dude embarrassing number of times then I
can't count the number of times what are
you talking about like you know it's it
happens like you know there was a phase
in my life it happened a lot and now it
happens less it's like okay you should
come to this party you'll have a good
time right like there's a version of the
doct gr question for like partying
there's a version of the doct Dr
question for you know like for parenting
there's a version of the do question
like uh I know a version of the question
for parenting is like what's the
grossest thing your kids ever done and
if they're like oh where where do I
start when they lick the urinal when
they uh you know at the airport decided
to like roll around on the you know this
is like a constant stream of like
fiascos that I've oh they pooped in my
bare hand uh you know because I couldn't
find the diaper in time like yeah these
things this is like I'm a I'm a seasoned
parent I've been through the wars of
parenting you know like you could tell
like kind of a first- time parent versus
second parent based on the number of
stories they have in college when I was
a degenerate my friends and I used to
say what's the best way to to get
through a blackout and manage it
effectively practice and we would
practice all the
time who's the most experienced uh all
right we want to do another one yeah
yeah I got another one Okay so we've
talked about one chart businesses before
and this is the idea
that like you could be the midwit in the
midwit meme where you gotta explain and
analyze and give you 10 reasons why this
might be a good idea the pros and the
cons and you're overanalyzing it or you
could just be the badass and the badass
the Jedi it just puts the one chart up
and says this is why I'm doing what I'm
doing the first example we gave of This
was um um what's it called when you
don't get buried you uh cremation uh
cremation it was like a chart of
percentage of funerals that are cre uh
people being cremated choosing to be
cremated and it went from 10% to over
50% and the guy sent us the the pitch
deck was like yeah we made cremation
easy but like this one chart is the
reason for our business existence this
is our business plan we are going to
ride this wave you've talked about how
uh Jeff Bezos did that about the
internet you I'm why do you quit his job
in finance to start an Internet company
Because the Internet was growing 23,000
per a year or something like that he's
like nothing grows that fast except for
bacteria to pacher Dish so I'm going to
go surf that wave yeah I mean there's
the internet there's there's mobile phon
you know like there's those big ones but
cremation was a smaller one that wasn't
as obvious and what are you saying as
the other one so there's a new one chart
I saw I saw yesterday that is not as
strong as those but is is legit and it's
the it's the growth in
homeschooling and so uh we kind of knew
when covid happened that there was like
a bunch of you know people created like
little home schools or whatever you
needed to teach your kids the schools
were closed what are you going to do but
it's actually sustained so it's now the
2023 data is out and homeschooling has
grown
I think like 40 or 50% a year
year-over-year for three straight years
like that's pretty aggressive and like
public schooling is like growing at like
you know whatever no perent 3% um
private schooling is like 7% and then
homeschooling is 40 to 50% every year
compounded for three years and like I
don't know if that's going to continue
or not but let's assume that that that
it is or that it might be that means
that a whole bunch of businesses that
were like not really that viable were
like to Niche are now perfectly Niche
and so there's like you know this trend
of um of of like micro school so out
school I think is like grown like crazy
yeah is is a micro School considered
homeschooling so there's homeschool
traditional homeschooling like uh J
Jenny's at home I'm just going to teach
her myself we're g to print out
worksheets and she's going to do them
and whatever I'm I'm the teacher then
there's micro schools which was like for
a variety of reasons I don't want my kid
to go to school for some people that was
Co for some people it's school shootings
for some people it's uh they don't like
the quality of the instruction for some
people it's the social they're worried
about like social peer pressure and like
you know kids bullying and things like
that whole bunch of reasons why people
might want to like take take the kid out
of traditional schools and so a micro
school is you hire six six families get
together and they basically say hey for
the cost of private school we can
actually just have like a literal
private school we can have our own pod
here like a hired teacher a Hired Gun
teacher that teacher makes double what
they make at a public school so like oh
instead of making whatever $50,000 a
year you make $100,000 a year uh so
we'll get the we'll get a great teacher
we'll pay them extremely well they only
have six kids to worry about they can
get super invest in them the teacher
student ratio is going to be really
really good instead of one teacher to 25
kids in a class there's GNA be one
teacher to six they're going to make
they're going to have friends and
socialize so it's not like homeschooling
like they still get the socializing
aspect of it and um there's same age
children they're like kind of like in a
yeah it's usually maybe like a little
broader range like it might be like a
year and a half window or something like
that two years window maybe and they'll
also be kind of an indoor outdoor
component so like sometimes they have a
dedicated facility sometimes it's like
our backyard or they rotate through the
parents backyards or whatever um
sometimes it's a mix of indoor and then
they go for like a long walk or a hike
or playground or whatever like the
teacher takes them indoor and Outdoors
they get a better mix than like sitting
in a desk all day um and this makes all
the sense of the world to me like I'm
I'm actually super interested in doing
this I think this is actually a pretty
pretty dope idea and then there's a
business called primer that uh Ryan Delk
started you are you familiar with Ryan
Delk and primer yeah Ryan Ryan's cool I
like Ryan a lot but I his company that
he started preco this was that company
right it was home school I think they
pivoted they started with more of that
traditional homeschool like what do you
do if you're if you're actually at home
and then now it's pivoted in the last
year to I think it's pivoted uh to M
these micro schools and it's basically
like an operating system it's like hey
if you're a teacher push this button
it's like stripe Atlas like you could
spin up your micro School it'll be
compliant with your State's regulations
you'll be able to accept all the
school's Choice vouchers so that's the
other one chart in this is that the
number of like I don't know this space
very well so I might get this slightly
wrong but apparently there's like a
school's Choice angle where like as a
parent you get like a $10,000 voucher
and you get to go shop around and figure
out what school is the most worthy of
getting your tuition so this the
government instead of just paying the
public school pays the family the family
shops around with that voucher and picks
the school that's doing the best or that
sells himself the best in order to send
their kid there and so the schools have
to kind of earn all the federal funding
or state funding that they're getting
from from the government makes a lot of
sense so now that thing is on the rise
like the number of states that do this
voucher program has gone up and up and
up like crazy and there's now thousands
of you know whatever uh you know uh uh
these vouchers that are High ticket
vouchers so if you build a successful
school you can attract these vouchers
you can basically get a bunch of Revenue
that the government has given the
families to pay you and so what primer
does is they're like all right uh spin
up a school be compliant accept vouchers
and have like your website have all that
done for you your back end parents
here's a parent portal students here's a
student portal we are the operating
system for micro schools I think they
have like three micro schools now and
they're trying to get to like six and
then they're going to get to like 18 and
uh you know each of these micro schools
basically generates like I don't know
75k of profit for the the owner right
now or could become 100K of profit for
the micros School owner after you pay
the teacher so let's say you you might
if you're the teacher and you do this
you might be able to make 75 to 100K on
the teacher wage plus another 75 to 100K
for your little franchise School your
the little Chipotle that you built here
and so I think this is kind of a cool
Trend and I'm I don't know if their
company's going to be the the winner or
like what's the right wedge to attack
here
like I would invest in this yeah I was
gonna ask is this the team is too legit
the price is going to be too high
they've already raised a bunch of money
because they've been going at this for
years and he's very like well connected
Silicon Valley I don't even know the
price but I already know it's too high
for me but I think this idea is actually
really great and highly investable
because of where the puck is going would
you s are you gonna your your kids are
going to be close to school age are you
gonna consider this yeah I definitely
want to consider this um I want to
either make my own pod or find a a a
school or a pod that's around here like
my daughter's about to go to to school
and um or she goes to like a preschool
right now a couple you know two days a
week for three hours or just to like get
acclimated and um you know it's kind of
underwhelming when you go because you're
like oh this is like you like you know
you can pick up the toy be like this is
from 1984 like is there new stuff
anywhere here like you know she that te
one teacher is supposed to manage all of
them like that's tough right you know
like 10 to one teacher student teacher
ratio that sounds really high uh I guess
I could go shop around and try to figure
this out but I don't know I'm I'm
willing to be sold by a service like
this I I'm ready and I think a lot of
people will be yeah I'm I'm will so I
went to private school almost my whole
life in St Louis you go to private
school and private school sounds a lot
fancier than I'm describing but my grade
school was like $800 a year and then I
think my high school when I it was like
10 grand a year nowadays I met like a
lot of private high schools are like
50,000 which was crazy mine was nothing
like that but what I my favorite part
about it was that the teachers could do
things to me that public school teachers
couldn't
whoa yeah sounds that sounds that sounds
weird when I but when I was they would
touch me in a great way
meaning when I was being an I
remember one teacher I was in the
hallway and I I was being rude and he
kind of pushed me against the locker and
he's like what the is your problem
and he like grabbed me by the collar and
I had a little bit of fear and I
remember thinking all right I if I I got
to act up otherwise there's going to be
consequences whereas my mother was uh
was a public school teacher and she
mostly worked with handicapped kids and
there'd be times where like the kids
would like literally themselves and
she's like I I can't go to the bathroom
with you I'm not allowed and I remember
like the difference in in how much they
could like care and like where that line
was and it and it made a big difference
to me so with the private school that
was allowed or this teacher just cross a
line and it happened cuz it sounds like
that proba wouldn't be allowed to grab a
kid by the caller shove him in the
locker and be like hey kid get your
together the way that I'm describing
it's a little bit more serious than
actually was but it was just like I
remember I was doing something stupid in
the locker in the in the hallway and and
the teacher got in my face and kind of
just like not like aggressively just
kind of pushed me and it's like what the
hell is your problem right uh like that
type of thing and like there was other
times where like I got in trouble at
home and like I had to like I had to go
to the the teacher in private school and
tell them what what was up and they're
like all right we'll help you out like I
just I remember the line was as to what
and I also by the way in high school I
went to an all boy school which I
freaking love all boy schools are
awesome because there's like I remember
being in ninth grade and like the
captain of the football team could also
be in a play and like I remember like
when kids came out as being gay like At
first you're like oh we're going to
tease them then it's like h no we're not
here to impress a girl like we can all
be homies and buddies like there was
there wasn't as much of a cool kid Club
anyway I loved all boy schools um but I
remember in the private school they
could just do things that my public
teacher mother couldn't do even though I
felt it was incredibly necessary uh and
this the rules are different and I
really appreciate that that private
school environment so we're debating at
our home even though we've got plenty of
time of what we're going to do with our
kids I a private school or I would
totally absolutely do one of these micro
schools I think this is awesome the the
only downside is like are you are you
gonna be a weirdo you know what I mean
um that is like my biggest fear which is
are you going to be the are you going to
be the wrong type of weird at least
they're with other kids right like it
might not be you know cuz I I remember a
lot of the source of social anxiety when
I was a kid was the fact
that I mean I just felt like I was like
you know have you ever watched like
Finding Nemo where he's like you know
he's looking around and all the other
fish are swimming really fast and
nowhere to go and it's like that's how I
felt most of school I just felt like
everybody else knew where to go knew
what to say knew what to do and I was
just sort of like lost I guess or and I
don't think I was actually that much
more lost than anybody else but I
certainly felt that way and there was
like because it's so big it's easy to be
lost uh it's easy to be lost in the
shuffle it's easy to just be quiet and
you know the teachers are he's just a
quiet kid that's it you know you sort of
give up on them you just sort of label
them that's who they are I don't have
time to go rescue every quiet kid and
try to get them out of their shell
whereas I think if you're in a school of
like six to eight kids even if you're on
the cheter side I think the teacher and
and and just the Dynamics would allow
you to come out of your own shell a
little bit more CU you could be more of
a big fish in a small pond and I think
that's really good when you're almost
like trying to get your your straight
your legs under you and trying to get
your your social legs under you yeah I
think for a lot of personalities that
could be beneficial we you and I have a
friend whose kid went to an alternative
style school where there was like no
homework and like no teachers they were
guides and all this thing and like he
was like man he's just like lacking
structure so he sends him to like a a
Catholic school where it's like you're
there at 8 school ends at 3 you have
homework and the kid needed the
structure he needed the discipline and
he started thriving in it and so I get
nervous because a lot of people they
just need to learn how to F in order to
be successful in life they got to figure
out how to follow rules how to work
within the rules and not be free roaming
all the time and they need to figure out
how to master grade school so they can
get into a good high school they got to
master high school just so they can get
into a good college and they have to do
good in college just so they can get a
job with a high paying starting with a
high starting salary and then they're
going to do that until 55 or 65 and
they're going to retire and they're
going to have grandkids like for a lot
of people I think that that linear route
of discipline is right decision and I
get nervous with some of the these
schools that that would happen of course
you and I are always going to say our
kids are going to be different or we're
in a different situation and we're g to
figure it out maybe that's true maybe
that's not true but that's what I get
nervous about some of these schools yeah
yeah I think it's definitely uh but but
you also wonder how much of it's
self-fulfilling meaning like how much of
it is nature versus nurture and and like
uh if you had that environment or if you
were if that was the expectation or the
norm for you that you were not expected
to go down that that linear path that
you just
described that you'd be like well I
guess that's what I'm doing like you
know my wife she grew up and in her
family everybody did business so for her
even when she had a job in her head
she's like oh this is the temporary part
before I have my own business and sure
enough now she has her own business like
you know like that happened um whereas
for me I grew up every single family
member Aunts Uncles cousins parents
everybody it was what you describe good
school get to good college good college
get to a good job
get a good salary get to a better salary
over time work your way up become a good
manager right what whatever it was I
knew zero people that did their own
business now I'm lucky that I got off
that track and I was able to to go into
the world business through other
influences but it would have but that
was not the default and in fact I think
if I played my life out you know eight
times out of 10 I would have been on the
the job side just because that's all I
knew that's what normal was and uh you
know I think if there's any like
takeaway there it's you
know if you want something if you have
inkling that you want something out of
your life you got to go where that's
normal that's why I liked moving to
Silicon Valley it was very normal here
for people to be starting a company with
a Half Bake idea and that was what the
smart capable people were doing it's not
what the like you know Fringe weirdos
were doing whereas everywhere else I
lived anybody who's like I quit my job
I'm gonna go work on this app for um
checking into restaurants people would
have been like H gu just weird and he's
off the he's off track and so uh you
know in silic and Valley if you're like
hey I took this job at this you know
working at JP Morgan it's like bro you
better have a side hustle if you're
trying to like get any respect around
here like you know you're that is not
what's the respected path it's a
literally just moving my body moved me
in the direction of who I wanted to be
because I just moved my body into a
place where the norm and the default and
the expected was you're G to go create a
company right that's what we do here um
and so I kind of think it's the same
thing with schooling like if you're
around if you're in a school environment
that expects you to be creative or
dynamic or like work on projects and not
just be like you know sit down and take
tests like I think that that's uh it's
going to be self-fulfilling in a way
dude I remember being in San Francisco
and I would meet people who worked at JP
Morgan or just had like a normal job but
they would introduce themselves as like
the founder of this thing and uh like
what is this thing and like oh it's just
a pro you know it's just a project I'm
working on but I and I used to make fun
of that back then I kind of like it
though I kind of like it like like their
side hustle or their main their main
work at their at JP Morgan no like the
well well I'm getting get this uh this
app off the ground but as a side hustle
I work 9 to5 at JP
Morgan no no they they turn into
cheating husbands they're like I work at
JB Morgan but it's not what it looks
like okay it's this is just a it's just
a thing it's temporary this is there not
an emotional connection to it I swear I
just had to do it you know like I just
two years that's all then I'm gonna do
it I'm gonna do the real thing I love
that um you want to wrap up talking
about poop
yeah let's talk about it Thanksgiving
I'm around a lot of family members a lot
of 13 14 people in my house right now
there's a lot of bathroom time going on
um fiber is everywhere dude I think
fiber supplements I think are a little
opportunity so uh you know people a lot
of people age 36 and up are uh are
taking fiber regularly and when I look
at these supplements you know
Metamucil fiber like these Brands just s
they literally sound like poop which
maybe is intentional but I think there's
an opportunity to make a a fiber
supplement that is uh you know just you
know what's going through that right now
what what's going through that right now
is creatine do you know what creatine is
bro don't make me Flex of course I know
what creatine is creatine's like I
believe it's the most studied supplement
of all time um but basically it's proven
like constantly where it just makes you
stronger and build more muscle mass I
don't know by what percent if it's like
one or two% but historically creatine
was powder form and it doesn't
necessarily have a a bad taste but
mostly it's neutral but there's this guy
it tastes fine it's mostly neutral but
you still like when you drink it it's
kind of chalky um but it's no big deal
but um I take creatine all the time I
love creatine and creatine when we were
kids when we were in high school that
was just like what the jock football
players
would muscles right it was like is this
bad for you it's going to mess up your
kidney and your liver or something like
that I was like I guess I stay away from
creating I'm not that I don't need I
don't need to be a bodybuilder right
like yeah and it and that's mostly
nonsense creatine it's it's just like uh
it's probably some health guy might yell
at me for saying this but it's basically
just like consuming more protein you
know like it's just like it should be
almost part of a of a daily routine like
it's a very stable thing you're not
particularly going to get sick whatever
it's it's just going to make you
stronger and build muscle but uh what's
pack what's the what's the bormi guy's
first name he's started a creatine
company that they basically made it like
a fln they made a Flintstone vitamin but
for creatine and he shares all of his
Revenue online and like six months after
starting the business I think it's doing
like $800,000 a month in sales and I
actually really appreciate that this
guy's doing this because he's taking an
old supplement that is wonderful um but
people are afraid of and it's not really
that easy to consume so with his stuff
he made it into like a a Flintstone
gummy bear like style supplement where
you could take because you can't really
take creatine in your bathroom unless
you have a cup there because you have to
mix it with water he is a chewable that
tastes kind of good and I think it's
really amazing what he's doing with
creatine so his name very fast his name
is Dan McCormick I'm gonna pull up
whatever his last update is so three
million in alltime Revenue so basically
looks like he's going to do about three
million in the first year December when
he started 21k January 64k and then it
basically goes up 128 172 244 and then
the the last two August September were
550k yeah so and what he's doing is he's
taking creatine and he's kind of making
it popular and and making it easier to
consume there's another drug or a
vitamin that I like it's called
ashwagandha do you know what that is yes
so ashwagandha a lot of people use it
for anxiety so there's ashwagandha and
then there's Cava so Cava I remember
drinking it in Fiji it looks like a mud
like it's like a powder and you mix it
with water and in Fiji they'll sit
around
a fire and drink Cava and it kind of
makes you a little bit high but if you
take it in small doses like you can get
you can buy Cava at the store and it's
and it calms you and ashwaganda is
another one like that and so I like
these ideas of taking a fiber an
ashwagandha a Cava something that has
decades or centuries of like proven
usage but it doesn't it's not packaged
in a way that seems very approachable I
think that's a very fascinating way to
go about this uh people years ago did it
with melatonin melatonin wasn't quite
popular now it's incredibly popular it's
a very accessible thing I love when
people do that with certain supplements
dude I have a supplement story that's
going to blow your mind and I'm not
going to tell you now I'm gonna tell you
like a year from now because it's
playing out right now uh I have a very
small part in this but it is wild to see
what a successful supplement company can
look like and it's too good right now I
can't say anything about it but can you
say what the drug or what the vitamin is
I'm not saying anything um that's how
you know it's good because I gotta just
shut up about it you're an investor in
it I'm not gonna say anything a year or
two from now uh I will tell the story
and it's gonna be unbelievable oh all
right I'm very eager I I'm very eager
you know at once we had Derek from more
plates more dates on and he talked about
his supplement business I thought like
that was it was pretty amazing um I
wonder if it's Derek blink twice I I'm
not saying anything I am I'm saving this
from you too because I want to see your
reaction when it all plays out uh I'm
not going to give you any hints either
before then would you um go into the
supplement business uh
yes I need my soundboard where's the
Bezos hell yes that's that's how I feel
that's how I feel about about the
supplement industry um yeah so I have
nothing to do with any supplement
business and from an outside perspective
it just seems like an overcrowded space
that's really challenging
it's very saturated I don't think it's
very I don't think it's necessarily like
um you know anybody can play but if
you're good it's the right type of
e-commerce business to be in um you know
I'm in the wrong type of e-commerce to
be in the hard slog e-commerce type of
business to be in if you're good like
you know it's somewhat binary I would
say in the supplement side like it's uh
you know the it's not easy to win but
once you get it going if you have the
right supplement and the right branding
and the right good market and the right
right advertising if you could stack
those blocks together in the right
formation it's a beautiful business why
supplements super high margin
supplements are repeat purchase
consumables supplements get bought by uh
you know bigger companies all the time
so the exit Market is fantastic the
multiples are good supplements can go
into retail really well the inventory is
very simple you only have like a limited
number of skews that you need to deal
with usually they're made in the United
States so your cycle time is very low
which means that you don't have a bunch
of money tied up in inventory any given
time you might even have negative cash
conversion so there's all these benefits
of the supplement category if you could
be in it um it's a clear problem
solution so it's easy to Market and it's
expensive I probably spend uh a hundred
bucks a month on on protein powders and
creatines and a few other things it's
it's expensive yeah for sure for
hundreds
probably I get a bag from Whole Foods
it's like 80 bucks I uh so my my
sister-in-law's in town this is just a
funny story so my sister-in-law's in
town I was telling her about this
supplement and uh she is I I remember
because at previous thanksgivings she
was like telling me about uh she's like
oh leaky gut oh you I was I was like I
was like yeah what is that I've kind of
heard that what the hell is that and
she's like it's brilliant branding she's
like oh my God you don't want leaky gut
imagine like a leaky gut like it's just
like you know like imagine your sewer
has a hole in it right your sewer Lin's
like you don't want that getting
everywhere no and she's like it's toxic
it's bad and I was like how do I know if
I have it she's like you probably have
it everybody's everybody has it I'm like
oh my God my gut health I've just been
totally neing my gut health over here
what am I doing I'm sleeping on my gut
health my microbiome is just a
mess right now and I was
like and so I'm and so I I was like hey
are you still into leaky gut she's like
I was like scale of 1 to 10 how into
leaky gut are you that was last year she
goes 500 I don't stop thinking about my
gut and I was like so tell me and I
literally recorded I have a voice memo
of her describing all of the things
she's like oh fiber yeah you got to have
the see this fiber is bad because look
it has all these extra ingredients
natural flavors you don't want that you
want this other one it's super clean a
garden of life it's got the three
different sours of fiber because then
you get the blend and when you get the
blend the three fibers and she's like
drawing these diagrams and then she's
like and then she's like yeah and like
um you know you just want to have Living
Water I was like whoa whoa whoa what's
that what's Living Water I don't know
what that is like have you heard of
Living Water no and so she's describing
living water and she's telling me about
that and then she's telling me about
this other thing and was laughing so
hard and I was like you are like if I
could take my Facebook pixel and I could
just show my Facebook pixel your face
I'd be like only advertised to this type
of woman like you know rich woman who's
like believes in all of these things is
like the best Market she is spending got
to be spending hundreds of dollars every
month $500 a month on just like for her
for her kids for her husband does she
consume all of it and then she's like
she's like yeah I she's like I wish
she's like I'm not even taking all the
stuff I should be taking I wish I was
more on top of it but I'm so busy with
life so that's why to to to supplement
for it that I do my water fast and I do
my 3day water fast because it's a detox
and I was like you do all the things and
that's really what you want is like if
you're going to build a product like
this you are advertising to these women
in in in women across America who are
like there's this demographic of women
that will will buy all of these products
and they will do the fast and they want
to alkalize their body and I'm not even
saying that this is all Bs like maybe
it's all true maybe it's all false I
have no idea like but they believe it's
true and as an entrepreneur that's all
that matters is that there are people
that that are all bought in like they
are bought fully into a lifestyle and in
that lifestyle you could then tack on
other angles so like you know who knew
that water could be dead or alive I
didn't that's a position that's a
product positioning play right um you
know who knew that you could um sell you
know collagen and like all of these
different angles to uh to to doing you
know to improving the quality of
somebody's Health in their body um and
it's just can you tell a story if you
could tell a story because she told me
all the stories she basically played
back to me you know ads Facebook ads
that she's read you know and and then
gone down the rabbit hole of reading
about and if you could tell the right
story that's fantastic like when Craig
Clemens was on and he talked about
probiotics and how he basically created
the probiotics Revolution did you listen
to that episode do you know that part no
I didn't hear that part you've heard of
probiotics probiotics were like a semi
big deal have you ever heard of
prebiotics Craig five minute abs CRA
Craig Clemens taught the world about
prebiotics yesterday when she was
talking she was talking about prebiotics
and I'm like you know my friend
literally like created that word like
there wasn't like maybe it existed but
nobody knew about it and uh I don't know
if you've seen this but Craig has this
video that he created this this one ad
that he he talked about on the Pod so I
can share it here he created one ad
called um The American Parasite have you
you heard of this and like Joe Rogan
tweeted it out he goes yo this video is
freaking me out this is back then it's
15 years ago now the video is like hard
to even find online I I found it but
like there's a um this ad called Amer
does look like a direct marketer video
uh no this one looks a little different
this looks like a TED Talk where uh you
know like the have you ever seen the
draw during a TED talk like there's a
TED Talk voice but the hand is drawing
on a whiteboard like what the guy saying
it's kind of like keeps your attention
and so he and Craig described this on
the podcast he's like basically this
went this this video went insanely viral
and I've heard him share on other
podcasts um so they they started with a
with a long form sales letter and and
they were selling these prebiotics and
they did like 10K the first day they
spent 10K and they they spent four or 5K
they made 50k he's like holy they
did that again did that again and they
sold out within like a week so then they
made a big bet they ordered they ordered
a million dollars of inventory for uh
for the Prebiotic because they believe
believe that this thing would sell when
it comes time and when they did it they
relaunched it when they got inventory
back in stock first day they did 500k in
sales second day they did 600k in sales
1.1 million in sales in two days when
this came back and he created this video
sales uh this video ad it's a 30 minute
basically documentary talking about how
our food supply is up how it
creates a bad you know like micro biome
in your gut and how that that's like the
he calls it the Great American parasite
that is you know eating away you know
it's it's ruining your health it's the
reason you can't control your Cravings
it's the reason you're gaining weight
it's the reason for all your problems
it's not you it's this parasite in your
stomach and isn't that a convenient
explanation that somebody wants to wrap
their their arms around and so he took
that and basically that thing was viewed
like hundreds of millions of times
people were sharing this like crazy this
was back when there wasn't a lot of ads
and so um the and people were a lot more
willing to share on social media when
they found an interesting video and so
this thing went crazy uh to the point
where he said that coke changed their
formula for Diet Coke they took asame
out on the because this video was
causing so much like public like you
know like awareness and an uproar over
these like fake sugars that people were
putting in things he's like and then
over six months like Coke sales went
down because Coke without as doesn't
taste as good and then they put it back
in like six to nine months later what
was the name of Craigs Keybiotics was
the name of his company back then oh and
it how much did it make a lot of money
oh my God
so he kind of popularized or created the
pre the Prebiotic Market in the United
States that's insane yeah I'm looking at
it now have you heard of um do you know
ancient
nutrition yeah that's the liver King guy
no it's a different guy but company yeah
no a different one uh ancient nutrition
they've raised $100 million do so I have
to imagine they're doing hundreds of
millions in revenue and it started
because this guy named Josh axe Dr axe
is what his name was or his name is and
he's got a of course it is of course his
name is Dr axe it's Dr axe spelled like
an Axe and he had a Blog and the
majority of the blog at the time it
talked about leaky gut and he would sell
info products on how to fix the leaky
gut and then eventually they were like
all right let's actually make stuff and
that's how ancient nutrition started uh
and it's like a huge huge business but a
lot of his whole thing was leaky gut and
he helped popularize leaky gut the The
Branding of leaky gut is like brilliant
brilliant
kind of like it's kind of like when
people talk about doing a cleanse and
they act like their blood is like a pipe
and like doing a cleanse is like putting
a pipe cleaner through it you it's like
it's like I don't know if arteries work
that way but image that now I automat
yeah like I don't even know if that's
true it probably even isn't but for some
reason you've made me believe that
that's how it is same with leaky gut
you're like so like first of all I don't
even know what a gut is is that your
colon so like this organ that has poop
in it is just leak leing to the rest of
my body is that what you're saying of
course that's a huge deal I don't want
poison in my body and I I don't even
know I have no idea if that's how it
works if it doesn't work but they do a
great job of making me believe it by
because of that phrase leaky gut right
right um yeah Scott Adams I forgot what
he called it like he had these two words
he said he said he had one that was
called a linguistic kill shot and then
he had another one that was about
visuals um so what did he say I forgot
what he called it but let's call it a
visual kill shot like I think that idea
of the pipe cleaner or the leaky gut
these are visual kill shots it's uh
words that make you see things and
they're things you can't unsee once
you've seen them right and it's like
that's and and and you know he Scott
Adams used to say Trump did this he
called Jeb Bush when Jeb Bush was the
front runner in the Republican debates
because he's you know he's a bush and
you know he's a whatever he was the
governor of Florida or whatever the hell
he was and there and then he goes low
energy Jeb
entired Jeb and basically every time you
look at Jeb Bush from then on out you're
like he does look low energy and
it just like yeah sleepy Joe sleepy Joe
right crooked Hillary right like she
does not just
like immoral Hillary or like uh you know
whatever crooked it's a visual word
right uh the wall it's GNA be a big
beautiful wall right like he wasn't
saying better border control policy he
said we're gonna build a big wall
beautiful wall biggest wall you've ever
seen right like you have a visual of the
Border being strong and protected and so
like Trump was kind of a master at this
and uh Scott Adams he's he's pretty
interesting the way he um he described
you know what what Trump was able to do
with these visual kill shots okay well
in one year we're gonna play the clip of
you saying I'm not going to tell you now
but we'll tell you in a year because I'm
very eager now you've got me on the hook
you've used you've used you've gotten me
you've gotten me hooked and I'm so eager
to know who it is I'm I'm eager to know
everything about it um so I guess we'll
end there and you got to come back and
year and tell me done um all right
that's the
[Music]
pod